okay today I'm going to talk to you
about enzymes in breakdown and synthesis
so we're going to look at three
different types of enzyme the type of
molecules they break down and also we're
going to talk about the importance of
synthesis as well okay
so let's get started the first type of
enzymes group of enzymes were going to
look at a called carbohydrate so
carbohydrate is so this is just any type
of enzyme that breaks down carbohydrates
member carbohydrates we find in like
pasta rice bread and they give us energy
now
the nice thing about most enzymes that
we come across is they end in a's so if
you see a word ending with a's we've
probably got an enzyme so the whole
point of being able to break this down
is so we could actually absorb it into
our body because let's say we have
carbohydrate here that we've eaten at
the moment this molecule is too big in
order to absorb it into our bloodstream
so if we didn't have enzymes to break
the break her food down then we wouldn't
be able to use it we would be able to
use it within our bodies so a particular
type of carbohydrate we need to know
about is called starch so there's just
an example now the enzyme that actually
breaks down starch is called amylase you
actually find a lot of this in our
saliva
now all that it does is it breaks the
bonds and breaks down this molecule to
make smaller soluble molecules that
means we can actually absorb them so we
actually break down carbohydrates into
simple sugars which we could then use in
the body so basically taking a large
insoluble molecule breaking it down
using amylase into simple sugars now the
second type of enzyme we need to know
about is called oh well it's a group
called proteases again it ends in AIDS
we have an enzyme on our hands
so what approach what protease does is
it breaks down protein big big clue in
the name that breaks down protein into
these smallest soluble substances
molecules called amino acids
amino acid so again we start off with
this thing this molecule here called
protein now this for example we find a
lot of protein in you let's see pulses
or meat things like steak
so again protein starts off as a large
in soluble molecule in order to be able
to absorb it into our bloodstream we
need to break it down and the enzyme to
do that are enzymes called proteases
again break him down so we can absorb it
so break down into amino acids now the
final type that we need to know about my
ones called lipase is again ends with
eight I know that I've got an enzyme on
my hands so what lipase breaks down in
fact whenever I hear the word lipid this
is a lipid right here a lipid molecule
whenever I hear lipid the first thing I
think of is fat because that's what
lipid means lipids or fats so just like
the other ones if I add this I would not
be able to absorb it into my bloodstream
in order to absorb it into my
bloodstream I need to break it down into
smaller parts I need to break it now so
again to break down a lipid I have
lipase notice how each of these is a
nice way of remembering it carbohydrates
breaks down carbohydrates protease
breaks down proteins like for ease
breaks down lipids so again what it's
broken down to it into is glycerol this
substance called glycerol and also fatty
acids so all that it's done again is
break down a large in soluble molecule
into smaller soluble molecules so you
could absorb them into the bloodstream
so here we have fatty acids okay so we
could see the importance of being able
to break down these larger molecules
into smaller molecules but what does
synthesis mean so whenever you hear
about C synthesis we know that it's
means making something because it's
important to break down these molecules
in order to absorb them into your
bloodstream in the first place but in
the body we need to make carbohydrates
we need to make proteins we need to make
lipids so it's a two-way process we
don't need to know the enzymes that go
the other way
but we need to know that enzymes can
also be used to put these things
together to synthesize to make these
types of molecules so we have enzymes
that can actually take simple sugars put
them together to form a carbohydrate we
can have enzymes that take amino acids
they're the building blocks of proteins
put them together and we synthesize a
protein and similarly we can also have
an enzyme or enzymes that assemble fatty
acids and glycerol to produce lipids so
those are the specific examples of
enzymes that we need to know we need to
know the different types of different
names of the enzymes what they break
down and what is formed as well we also
need to be aware that enzymes can be
used to make things as well as break
things down and the science of word for
making something is synthesis thank you